حكيمي في نيويورك ميسي عضو لتدريبات سان
جيرمان
ممنوع من دخول امريكا هذه الاخبار وغيرها
نقدمها لكم من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد حضور امام مباراه
بعده وصولهما مع فرنسا والمغرب لادوار
المتقدمه من بطوله كاس العالم
نبقى مع اخباري سان جيرمان وبعد نحو
الاسبوعين من الفوز بكاس العالم عاد نجم
الارجنتين ليو ميسي الى التدريبات نادي
ونشر حساب سانجر على تويتر صوران لوصول
القائد الارجنتين ولقائه بيزملائه كما
قاموا ما مره شرفيا واصطاد تصفيقات نيمار
وبقيه النجوم قبل ان يقدم له لويس كامبوس
المستشار الكروي في النادي درعا صغيرا
كنوع من التكريم له على هذا الانجاز
وفي ايطاليا فرض البرتغاليوب رقم مميز بعد
مباراه فريقه ميلان امام
افتتحت التسجيل للفريق في مباراه اليوم
وهي اول مباراه لميلان في العام الجديد
لكنها ليست المره الاولى التي يحرز فيها
اليوم او ولا اهداف فريقه في السنه
الجديده اذ فعلها العام الماضي والعام
الذي سبقه
يبدو انا بطله
ميامي واندين
المقبلين بعد قرار السلطات الامريكيه
اليوم الاربعاء مواصلات طلبيه لقاح فيروس
كورونا لغير الامريكيين الراغبين في دخول
البلاد وذلك حتى العاشر من ابريل المقبل
على الاقل ويعد النجم الصربي من اشد
المعارضين لتلاقي لقاح الفايروس وكانت
النتيجه غيابه عن بطوله امريكا المفتوحه
للتنس العام الماضي
[موسيقى]